次の偈もほとんど同じですから
一緒にやった方が私は楽です
四十八番も プッハニヘワパチナンタン
ビャサッタマナサンナラン
アティッタンイェワカーメスー
アンタコー クルテーワサン
プッハニヘワパチナンタン
ビャサッタマナサンナラン
アティッタンイェワカーメスー
アンタコークルテーワサン
という偈です 一 二行目まで同じですね
興奮状態で花を集めているように
ような感じで アティッタンイェワカーメスー
それだけなんで違うのは
アティッタンというのはまだ満足していない
カーメスーっていうのは世の中の楽しみなんですね
世の中の楽しみにいまだ満足しないうちにアンタコークルテーワサン
アンタコーっていうのは死ですよ
死をですね の手元に入ってしまいますと
死をに [咳] 任されてしまいますよと
いわゆる死んでしまいますよ
それは事実ですよ 我々は興奮状態で
あれも食べたい これも食べたい
あれも見たい これも見たいとかね
ずっと心の中でもまだ満足していないんです
生きることには やりたいことはものすごくいっぱいあって
やって終わったことというのはほとんど少ないんですね
あ これもやりました あれもやりましたというふうな考え方は人間にないでしょう
よくよく自分の心を見てください
自分の人生を あ 私はもうこれもできましたと
これもできましたと これもできましたというふうな満足の話は出てこないんですよ
やりたい話 夢の話だったら無限に出てくるんです
できればあれもやりたい
できればこれもやりたいと
この我々やりたいやりたいこと全て欲世界のことを楽しむことなんですよ
できれば死ぬ前にもう世間のいろいろもう国々を見たいとかね
別にそんな知識的なことじゃなくて
ただ単にそれ あー楽しい楽しい楽しみたいだけの話なんですよ
イタリア料理も食べてみたい
フランス料理も食べてみたいとかね
だからこのただ日常 我々は眼耳鼻舌身というこの欲
目耳鼻舌体を楽しませるものをもっとやりたいのに
人が死ぬんですよ やる
やるべき やりたいことは全部終わりましたという気分で死ぬ人はいません
先に死ぬ 惜しいという状態でみんな死ぬんです
だから前の偈でもね 準備していないままっていうことは
もっと生きていきたいという気持ち
気分でいるんですね 夜寝る人は朝起きていろんなことをやりたいという計画があって夜寝るんですね
そこで夜死んじゃうと
もうやっぱり惜しいんですよ
だから 寝る前に もしかすると起きられ起きられないかもしれませんよと思って寝た方がいいんです
私みたいに 全然思わない
明日あれやる これやるとか
とことん眠くなるまでなんとか本でも読むとは思ってますけどね
それを覚えておこうとも思わないんです
だから普通人間っていうのは
これあれやりたいというものがいっぱいあって
そういうものはまだまだ残っているのにも関わらず死んでしまう
アティッターン イーヴァ カーメスっていうのはたった二言葉でそれを言ってるんです
英語に入りちゃうと言葉ミスになりますけどね
イーヴァっていうのは強調で
アティッターンっていうのは満足しないままに
満足しないのにも関わらずという強調なんですね
イーヴァ カーメス 欲に対して
それで死が来て はい こっちいらっしゃいと言うと行かなくちゃいけないんですね
死神は待ってませんよ
じゃあこれ じゃあやってください
待ちますよとか あんた子供を一人前にするまで
じゃあ待ってあげますとかね
死ぬ じゃあもうあんた子供たちに別れの挨拶しなかったんで
じゃあ子供たち来て別れをするまで待ちますよとか
それは死は待ちません
死ぬ時は死ぬと だから準備するということは
いつ死んでもOKだというふうな状態でいなくちゃいけないんです
だから そういう人だけ充実して生きてるんですよ
人生は短くて儚いものだと知っている人は
自分の能力を知っているんだからね
自分に何ができて何ができないのかと
どんな夢が叶えるのかと知ってるでしょうに
夢作ったっても叶える夢作る
それでも死ななかった
死ななかったならばということで
もし明日も生きている
生きていることをできるならば
もう京都に行くぞとかね
そういうふうなことになってくると
京都に行くことは結構楽しいんですよ
普通よりは まあやっぱり今日まだ死んでないんだから
では まあ今日京都に行くことを考えたんだから
じゃあ行くぞと まあ二度と見られないかもしれませんだからね
きちんと見る 私は一人で旅をするんだったら
あんまりしたことはないんですけど
一回で全部覚えてるんです
二回は行こうとは思うないんです
どうも誰かがすごい鋭い頭のいい人がついてくるんだから最悪
無知で無明で妄想で もう耐えれませんね
だからどうしてもこの時間は付き合いしなくちゃいけないんだっていうことで
まあこれで私の過去の業でもね
悪業でも減ってくれるんだからということで我慢するんです
それでも私は心の中でふざけてます
一緒に誰かと何か楽しいところを旅するのは
もう言うんですけどね
楽しくはないんですけどね
無知な人と一緒に行ったっても観察能力はないわ
ものは見えないわ 固定概念で見ているわ
もう無茶苦茶だからね
それが私にとっては苦しいしね
それで私はじゃあこれで一部は過去の悪業は消えると
いうことでふざけますけど
全部言っちゃうと私の楽しみが消えちゃいますけどね
もう先がないんだから
もう別に秘密にしたって意味がないんですから
言います 今までは秘密にしておいたんです
私の先はもう随分短くなってますからね
だから 例えば命は短いと知っている人だったらね
春先 京都に行ったならば
まあもしかするとこれっきりかもしれませんよと
言うと結構楽しく見られますよ
もうもう食い物を持って行って
なんて幸せですか 生きていてよかったとかね
あれはああいうところですがっても
食べることにしか頭がいかないんですね
だからやっぱり見られないと思いますよ
で あの意味は同じですからね
まあ人間っていうのはもうそうやってやりたいことばっかり増やして増やして増やして
それでものすごく暗くなるんです
ものすごい精神的なストレス溜まるんですよ
それ屁理屈ですよ やりたいことはあってもあっても
生きていればの話ですから
そんなに真剣に考える必要はないんです
やりたいこと で やりたいことやれるかもわからないし
そこを頭に叩いて脳細胞はもう壊したい放題壊しちゃって
もう耐えられないほどストレスを作って
わざわざと 苦しんでイライライライラで生きてるっていうことは何の意味あるのかと
だからその強烈なストレスと
その苦しみを排除するためには
死を認めるしかないんです
しっかりと まあ人間っていうのはもういつでも死ぬやつだよと
あれもそれも生きていればやるもんだよと
いうことになってくると
別にやりたい仕事いっぱい溜まることはないんです
では 俗世間の人間っていうのは
もうやりたいことは無限大にあって
やって終わって満足したことっていうのは稀に少ないし
それで計算してみると不幸でしょうね
人生は だから死なないんだぞと思ったことで
もう不幸な人生で それが暗い人生になるんです
死ぬんだよと思った途端
人生明るくなるんです
ストレスはなくなるんです
だから 現代人のこの強烈なストレスを解放するためには
そういう理性で事実を見つめるしかないんです
[ silence ]